go through Google just put it all on
Google and then when you switch to any
phone you just go back to Google I'm not
going to trust some dancer to tell me
what to do with that
[Music]
have you guys heard about Apple
launching buy now pay later
is that like layaway I know I think so I
think some websites you can like go up
there and just buy it and then it's like
a turns into a payment program like
you're paying for you guys know about
apples here right yeah
so what about Apple pay later right
sounds racist
it comes with plans for for eligible
users right yeah in the coming months so
um this was supposed to come out last
September they had some delays but
essentially it's going to allow users to
split the cost of their purchases
purchases into four interest free
payments spread over six weeks paid for
it kind of like PayPal I mean I've
bought stuff on Apple pay where they
give you interest-free monthly payments
on stuff yeah but it's like two weeks
wow oh they send a 5 000 firing squad to
your house no
um they delete all your data on your
phone yeah no so basically you're
getting a loan right so so you're gonna
apply for a loan right they go in ranges
from fifty dollars to a thousand dollars
they can also be used for online and in
app purchases made on the iPhone or iPad
with Merchants that except Apple pay
already and there's no one-size-fits-all
approach they're saying many people are
looking for flexible payment options
it's like how Walmart has layaway like
they're trying to reach more people with
their services Apple seems that's kind
of cool feels like a scammer's dream a
little bit that's kind of what people
are afraid of right like the uh the way
that there's almost like an ease of
access to getting loans but it's all
it's no different than applying for a
credit card right now
the scammers do try to pay later and
they don't pay it later it's not that
much that they're losing because it's if
it's four payments it's like little it's
like smaller things right well it
depends because credit cards are not
accepted as a loan repayment method so
I'm only saying that because like the
stuff that I buy with like PayPal they
let you do paid for but I only buy stuff
that's like around 50 to 100 range and
usually that's when they offer that for
okay they don't offer it for like huge
well yeah you know you're not buying
graphics cards or anything yeah yeah
yeah but for graphics cards quite a lot
of sunglasses I heard yeah a little one
more than you need have you guys gone
and checked your like statements or
transactions sometimes there'll be a
link that says you can split the payment
up yeah on some transactions that are
like a thousand or above or something
right I've never clicked it but I was
like that's new
well the people who use the service are
they tend to have lower credit scores
so there's an argument to be made about
like is this like targeting people right
right it's like check cashing places how
they're targeting the ports and keep
them like
they're growing their Venn diagram for
business right it's like monetizing
someone's bad habit this does make it
more accessible does it tell you what
the APR is if you don't pay like the
because that's where they get you oh
yeah because I have I thought it was
weird how they could make it work like I
like I I bought an iPad and I mean um
you know I bought Apple products I I
just stack it onto my Apple pay thing
and I just have it in payments so I'm
like paying like 200 bucks a month zero
interest I'm like how can they even do
this right and I didn't even think about
what if I miss a payment Ah that's where
they get yeah yeah yeah it's zero
percent until you miss a payment yeah
that's why it's great for people that
already know their consistent income and
then you just basically don't even have
to worry about it but you don't have to
pay all your money up front it's great
you know but yeah it doesn't say much
about the the rate but it does their
base basically trying to clean up their
image privacy wise because like how can
you prove that you actually applied for
the loan it's just saying like oh well
you know regulatory wise we can prove it
through face ID Touch ID or passcode so
it's like undeniably you right right
yeah
um and then the user's transaction and
Loan history I never shared or sold
third parties for marketing or
advertising which happens sometimes it's
the same version on the up and up ever
since uh Mr Mr Hobbs passed away I'm
worried about the the um what like
Innovation design wise and all that
stuff are they going to come out with
because like you're Mr Hobbs
the Spanish pronunciation of Steve Jobs
you should have known I should have
known I was gonna use the Portuguese
pronunciation
Calvin Hobbs died yeah
that's their yobs all right yeah
obviously yeah so I thought I was like
Hops and shots it's their jobs all right
stop taking my job
you know a lot of people talk [__] like
oh Apple they're not forward on
technology Samsung been having that and
I'm like yeah we all know but we like
the design like it's easy to [__] use
and like how it's like I'm not a loser
I'm stuck I'm a loser I can't get out
well I got my photos and they delete all
your photos if you [__] move oh [__]
oh huh yeah when you move I don't know
how to get to a Samsung or Android yeah
it's like your photos you can't Port
them over easy all kinds of [__] go
through Google just put it all on Google
and then when you switch to any phone
you just go back to Google I'm not gonna
trust some dancer to tell me what to do
with that
there's also a drop box too it's a
delete Dropbox okay yeah this guy knows
how to delete everything I'm gonna trust
him yeah
hey hey when I need to delete something
and really make sure it's gone I'll ask
empty recycle bin
do you use anything like this ever
like this yeah yeah with PayPal what do
you do
um well sometimes like I know I spend a
lot on certain things like food and gas
and stuff but I rarely spend stuff on
like toys like I don't know stuff that I
do with my friends or whatever like sex
toys like dildos yeah
I didn't want to think about cat in that
way it looks like times and then
sometimes it's like I don't really want
to spend it all at once so I'm like you
know what pay it in four I'll pay 20
bucks this week a couple weeks later pay
another 20 bucks it's like way easier
and I know for sure like I can pay it
off
so I don't know I I just like it doing
it that way so they say I get to keep my
money do they send you the Dark Knight
first or do you have to pay for it I
still haven't bought it yet man I don't
know I got to do it in payments you know
the you know the thing that you have in
your shower the thing that's mounted
with the Dark Knight no the thing that
you're [__] in the shower whenever
you're in your shower can you explain it
like yeah so it's that it's that thing
that you put your dick in when you're in
your own shower
wall no way yeah that you plugged in is
that is that the ad on the on PornHub
sucking your dick it goes crazy
yeah it's like a gyroscope [__] goes
this direction and this direction it
looks like intimidating oh yeah I do I
do the opposite thing I I buy very I buy
virgin things like Gundam you know
that's a virgin thing yeah because you
should buy condom not Gundam
I've seen stuff that's similar on a
bunch of websites they can go on a
website and then it's like can't like
pay the whole thing now and there's
already like those things
built into it yeah so it's almost like
many loans on almost anything you can
buy sunglasses clothes whatever do you
guys like payments or do you like to pay
the whole thing off I like to pay the
whole thing I don't know why I don't
know if that's like I'm old-fashioned or
something I'm scared I like to pay the
whole thing because of bandwidth like in
my brain I don't like keeping track of
other [__] and I know like as soon as
it's like out of sight out of mind and
later on I'm gonna probably forget about
it and then I'll like Miss a payment I
just it's just too much I had a brush
with debt in the mid 2000s you don't
forget that [__] just pay it off
yeah it's all auto pay it takes way too
long to get out of that [__] I think my
mindset is more so like if I don't have
to give them all my money now like why
should I but I I know I will eventually
but like let's say something happens
[__] you know no but I get to keep I get
to keep the money that I have still
you're badass if let's say that company
goes out of business or something and
all their Productions company won't go
out of business or if something happens
you still keep you still have your money
you can't like I find out about this
company and I'm like I'm not gonna give
them all my money at once but I will
give them all my money eventually
over a six week period [__] dude because
like the stuff that I buy it's like it's
not that important you know but let's
say I have an emergency you gotta get a
dragon balls jacket like in a in a pinch
paying a hospital bill that makes sense
if you're doing this yeah so I would
rather have that money just in case I
like I rather I would rather uh what do
you call it not pay them for whatever
because it's such a small payment then
that makes sense yeah
free up capital
but if you have a lot of money then I
guess it doesn't matter just buy it and
it depends on what you're doing payments
on like I'm not gonna do payments on a
skateboard I'm like oh
it also depends on if you're trying to
build your credit too right if you want
to show that you're um look I'm paying
off that's the only reason I've ever
used credit cards yeah exactly yeah just
to build credit like
otherwise it's it could be a slippery
slope yeah it's also good for points
points and it's also good because like
if someone buys [__] like fraud and all
that you don't want them to use your
debit card yeah you can't get your money
back I recently bought a Nintendo switch
controller that I thought was like legit
and then I was like oh [__] they didn't
they didn't send me like an email to
confirm this I think I just lost my
money but then I just contacted there's
a lot even even on Amazon you could
accidentally buy a Chinese joy-con
that's not legit on actual Amazon yeah
they mess up too sometimes I got I got
scammed on a
oh I got scammed on a um Instagram ad
dude
this um loses [__] inflatable paddle
board right it was so sick so sick and I
was like oh my God I can't believe it's
only 30 bucks and I [__] bought it it
was just a paddle dude I didn't get
scammed but Gordon Ramsay got me on an
Instagram ad I bought his new [__]
hex clad pants and they're like look at
this it's non-stick and I could take a
knife straight to it oh God that's
pretty [__] sweet and then they do uh
like 60 off right now and then I know I
know marketing [__] tricks I know
they probably already marked it up sixty
percent that takes it yeah oh no but I
was like but still buy it Gordon Ramsay
Cooks on me it's a deal yeah same [__]
happened to me too did you find them but
they actually work pretty good oh wait
what's this
I don't need extra power I had the same
[__] happen to me with Instagram it
looks great it works as advertised no
with Instagram Target ads they got me on
Giada nudes and I thought they were
going to be her and it was clearly
doctored and [__] they sent me like a
70 [__] five photos and it was all
doctored and it wasn't even Gianna Giada
at home shift yeah yeah holy [__] she
has nudes no she doesn't that's so crazy
yeah I spent 525 thanks
for an album of complete fakes yeah and
she had a big head too I was like this
is totally fake that always happens to
me on yes style you guys ever shot that
yes Style no it's like a Korean clothing
site that a lot of the time they just
send you random [__] you just like you
look at the picture I want that shirt
they just send you a random actress oh
[__]
yeah they just send yourself a random
Triple A shirt you're like what is this
I think online shopping nowadays is kind
of scary yeah it depends man it's like
you got to be so good at it hey that's a
hot day
[Music]
foreign